qué podemos hacer para hacer de la
educación media en américa lo mejor
posible hoy en día si estás interesado
una obra en directo si estás realmente
interesado en aprender entonces estos
tiempos son una gran oportunidad para
todos si tienes acceso a la red sitios
como wikipedia a toda la información que
está en las ruedas en especial hay un
sitio que se llama khan academy que
estás haciendo con mis hijos
kh en este en donde una persona en 15
minutos
hace unos tutoriales extraordinarios
algunos de temas académicos a nivel
universitario
así que si hoy estás realmente motivado
puedes ir directamente a las grandes
lecciones ahora hablando de la
distribución de los recursos de las
sociedades creo que en algunas de las
pláticas lo has mencionado en especial
en harvard que la distribución de
nuestra inteligencia hacia entidades
como wal street y a los instrumentos
financieros que utilizan es mayor
tal vez debería de ser y que esos
recursos de inteligencia deberían de
distribuirse en otras actividades
bueno si decimos que podríamos dedicar
parte de su inteligencia a estudiar a
los grandes maestros y documentar sus
prácticas y difundirlas
cuáles son los componentes importantes
en educación y el costo sería realmente
bajo de lo que puedes imaginar que es lo
más importante en nuestras sociedades
sino hacerlas con oportunidades iguales
para todos y competitivas con otras
naciones y eso sólo se logra a través de
la educación en este sentido si hay una
terrible mala asignación por ejemplo una
de las cosas que me fascinan de este
hombre
salman khan es que él era un analista
financiero haciendo mucho dinero y de
pronto abandonó todo para dedicarse a
hacer estas lecciones en vídeo podríamos
decir que tomamos ese gran índice de
inteligencia en toda la gente de la
lista financiero y lo desplazamos hacia
la mente de la enseñanza yo creo que ese
fue un gran día ese día en que su esposa
dijo abandonar el trabajo